the fast sagas God's eye holds the key
to surveillance Secrets Revenge plots
and high-tech hijinks but is it a
blessing or a curse for Dom's crew in
his quest to torment and eventually
murder Dominic Toretto for the death of
his father and the destruction of his
family's criminal Empire fast exes Dante
Reyes has a wealth of resources at his
command yet in an Arsenal that includes
deadly mercenaries Advanced explosives
and more cars than could fill a highway
the greatest tool he has access to is
the machine known as God's eye
everyone that gets every camera
every audio device in this hemisphere
God's eye is an immensely powerful
technological device capable of hacking
compiling and sorting massive amounts of
data in a matter of minutes its main
function is to operate as a futuristic
surveillance system that would give even
Jonathan Nolan cause for concern if
you've seen The Dark Knight or the
series Person of Interest God's eye is
pretty much just a scaled up version of
the surveillance system seen in those
stories essentially God's eye is able to
hack into any device with a camera
coordinate with facial recognition
software and tell its user where a
specific human is located anywhere on
the globe so long as they've been seen
by a photographic device though it may
be confused by audiences as software or
some sort of algorithm it is seemingly
portrayed throughout the series as a
physical device that can be taken well
physically
all that trouble for this little
thing
it is unknown what limitations if any
God's eye has or if it could be used to
hack devices for purposes other than
visual surveillance for example if it
can hack into traffic cameras it may be
able to hack into computers to obtain
personal information though that may
simply be an unnecessary application for
the device as Ramsay can do so without
it despite being highly Advanced God's
eye is vulnerable to proximity-based
hacking only if the hacker in question
possesses the right skills and Equipment
its history and exact beginning are far
more complicated than you'd think it
requires going back several years into
the fast Saga to explain how it all
began then again if God's eye didn't
have an ever-changing backstory it
wouldn't be at home in the Fast and
Furious franchise in the first place the
technology was invented by Ramsay
sometime before the events of Furious 7
and quickly attracted the attention of
the sociopathic hacker terrorist Cipher
Cipher hired the mercenary mosaic to
retrieve God's eye on her behalf but not
before Ramsay sent it to a trusted
friend in Abu Dhabi for safe keeping
Ramsay was briefly kidnapped by jacande
and subsequently saved by Dom's crew who
were operating at the behest of Mr
Nobody and the agency despite a few
hiccups Ramsay and her new teammates
were able to secure God's eye for the
agency and defeat akande for good in the
fate of the Furious however Cipher
steals the device for herself and uses
it against Dom's former crew members in
usual Fast and Furious style she was
eventually thwarted and God's eye was
once again returned to the agency
overall the powerful Technologies played
a major role in almost every fast film
since its introduction usually to let
one side of the battle find the other
without the need for Creative problem
solving though it's refreshingly
consistent for the franchise to keep the
God's eye in play all these years later
they may just be reaching a narrative
dead end where they need to commission
this predictable machine for good
[Music]